the man who would be Rick and really
good Glen Steven Yeun also Carl Chandler
Riggs Michelle tenaglia who's teanna
Michael Douglas the wonderful Carol
Melissa McBride Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
take these or I'll kill you also Lennie
James is here Sunita 13 and of course I
mr. Norman Reedus your 2015 walking cast
[Applause]
taking pictures so everyone please have
a seat let's let's get in this so on
kirkman and as you know for the poor
mantle of it ill and he was not able to
attend this year so he's now here at t
shirt form here at mass farm yeah yes
done hand me one of those I'm he's
actually here any questions and come up
my god I kind of prefer to we just
drinking some oil everyone have one we
should definitely throw enemies into the
audience so on ok before we get started
right let's do this I how big is halogen
about 7,000 7,000 people yeah now it
would be great hello haulage I
it would be great to have the premier
somewhere that can hold this many people
it would be even better if we get old it
somewhere that would hold twice as many
people right it would be priced better
right if you could hold about two and a
half amount of this people where are you
going with this math problem the walking
dead premier is going to madison square
garden in the power all these people can
conceivably come if we have friends and
family friends family loved ones
well-wishers go to www that's hht p
please do the lumbar backslash backslash
lawrence lpw AMC AMC the walking dead
calm come join us in New York in October
for the big premiere yet thank you I
think that section back there's like
we live in New York but you guys
amazing mean assets regard about 20
pounds of people so that's the best way
Stephen just seeing you guys reacting
the trailer and young person most of us
watch this on like computer screens you
know oh just a room like this with a
screen like this with a crowd of
everyone freaking out it's definitely
experienced and we really appreciate it
so I'm going to I'm gonna launch into
fan questions before you do that just
what I just want Robert to react
everybody watching it on the computer
screen
okay sorry anything alright so let's get
into this this is this is from our dash
venkata will this is for the producers
well season six explorer power source
between Rickett morgan it kind of seemed
like that from the trailer we saw or
will it more so be portrayed as a
fundamental challenge the way rick has
always been meeting oh my well it
certainly seemed that we were selling
that in the t divided the trailer rather
i will say that this is a savvy audience
that knows that we sometimes play with
the truth in trailers right what it's
true history but it's just so you
maintain the experience for everybody i
would say that Rick absolutely is faced
with with challenges to the way he does
things and also including these people
in the way that he does things at the
end of season six he wanted everybody on
board with him and everything went very
well in those last few moments up until
shut except for the fortunate thing
that's you know exactly no really no
it's not me no I said it but that poor
guy has to live that precipice Horry
Brill is not a porch dick he just plays
one on TV it did you know like a week
afterwards I something he was like by
the way thanks people are shouting
Portuguese
[Music]
well he's a really nice guy do the love
was made that funnier but you're saying
that their things might not be as they
see things might not be as they see him
but ribbit absolutely has to deal with
the fact that things went down with
ridge and with Pete and all these people
might have been following him into the
bowels of how r maybe looking him a
little differently all right this is
this question is from Kerry Frazier I
will we get to see some more flashbacks
at a character past I'd like to know
more about some of them like lighter
Sasha Dave Alpert you want to take that
one okay you know what is anything can
you repeat the question we need see more
much max their other characters oh
there's a little bit of flashback mean
there's definitely some playing with
time but not quite as much classes okay
next question is from high and 25 will
the wolves from season five finale
finally play a big part in season six
the Wolves will be a part of season six
hopefully in a way that you don't expect
all right Chris good of almost answered
yeah this one's for Andrew Lincoln just
honey i emulate can I just say so lovely
to see you all again hello
what are you doing in my front room it's
crazy I feel like I can't believe
another years gone by already we're here
music we're just here oh no I sell every
single day this first questions this
first question is a hardball here Dylan
Hinchey wants to know you think Rick
misses the beard and you miss having the
beard my wife doesn't miss to see it but
uh yeah I think that was one of the most
weird filming days in my life when I had
to shave but I had to get it because it
was shower naked in front of my crew are
you offer you offer to get a shower
naked every night but then apparently
you can only see what had two inches is
my butt crack is that right is that a
patient the vs. there was no prayer no
Charlie colli colli Oh could confirm
that what are we allowed to say but yeah
I had to do that then I had to shave and
look in a mirror the most believe i was
actually looking at my face while
shaving because i don't enjoy that
experience anyway but to do it on camera
was just unbearable but yeah I missed
that beard and I'm going to grow it back
as soon as possible Scott Gimple how
much does what's how much does having
that beer to become sort of a proper on
the character like when you have the
beer does it inform the way your books
character post when you shave off the
beard well you will Steven Yeun look to
me when I showed up he said you look
like you have a shrunken head and nerve
me for the afternoon filming but it
because it does it became part of him
you know and also I remember sort of two
seasons before Scott actually talking to
me just saying we want to get these guys
at the lowest air and I feel well the
great way of doing that is sick how big
I can push it i can grow my beard a nice
light just like Scott kept all right
then yeah I'm working on it yeah that's
exactly what you know what somewhere you
just touching my cheek like that Robert
Kirk days smiling
that's usually his job I will say that
the beard folks at the comic and the
show really is sort of a metric of where
work is that right and when Rick shaved
appeared when he went Alexandria I mean
we in the comic we completely beard that
and it was in a mirror and the I can't
believe people have to thank you i will
say that the beard the beard will
continue to inform and sort of indicates
a barometer where it is at this man's
twitter name at that guy wants to know
this twitter name to you aged men yet
what today am i going to be like between
Rick and Deanna the season obviously the
last moment was very unhappy so where
where are they at this point that you
can say bravery at the enemies are
having a blood is going right yeah i
think that there's a genuine respect
between the two videos between Diana and
Rick and a lot of the last sort of three
or four episodes you saw a man
restraining his instinct to leave and to
show these people and then as things
started they really he realizes that
he's amongst innocents and people that
don't have any experiences out there I
think you know we got lucky the gates
were open you know we go walk as I had a
zombie shower again when I blew his
brains out and him and then and then of
course you know when he came in here
slashes bridge and I am I shot him yeah
but that was it wasn't just that you
shot me that was Deanna it was an
execution again are urging that you
actually do it y'all was gonna do
anywhere but uh well that just means you
guys were simpatico yeah but that was
that struck between the whole time and
so you have this insulating community
that things things can still be the way
they were for the apocalypse because
they're clearly lying for themselves
their week they're not trained they
don't understand what the world is like
you guys come in and effectively sort of
them for the better but you had to show
them that this is how things have to be
now I agree and I think I think
certainly a lot of the themes it seems
to be we're exploring the season are
about diamond else you know inside the
community and outsides William Herman
and then you have the wild card of
Morgan returning just at that moment
yeah and what he's seen being a very
different grip from the last time I just
move it as well maybe more we don't
really know at this point yes we don't
really know what he's up to what's going
on but he's damn good in fighting with
that stick this is for denying this is
from aisha crimes on instagram what do
you think Michelle's opinion is on
Carol's housewife disguise and relying
about stealing guns in Alexandria
question I always yearned for more
interaction between Michelle and Karen I
[Music]
share the 7,000 people and my possible
because I just I endure Carolina is such
an interesting thing between these two
women I think there are two tactics of
how to handle this world is just so it's
so interestingly they're both having
tactics but there they couldn't be more
different I think she really is just
catching up we weren't Harrell doesn't
she has a profound respect for Carol so
if she understands that what Carol is
doing is for the good of the group and
it's definitely about protection it's
definitely about keeping us you know on
talk and keeping us safe but it's just
not the way that she wants to to grab
her things in this moment she's looking
to actually merge community but she's
not going to get up you know into a big
tussle with her and like she did in that
same she just acknowledged as where she
was actually really getting the
landscape where everyone was but I mean
I was um I would I love to hear them
converse about their different ways of
seeing the world so this is sort of a
two-part question what what do you think
Michelle's journey was in the last
season and especially that last thing
with her and the katana like sort of
embracing that again
where do you think she ends up yeah yeah
i mean it is it was really fascinating
actually because she was there and she
has made that decision in in cpep season
4 where she literally decided i'm
actually going to stop being this
isolated character like goes off by
herself brats to pets and we'll go and
venture into the world and be alone and
hang out with walkers with rest of my
life and not be wonderful to anybody and
making that decision to turn around and
say I'm going to reimburse my people and
i'm going to real race whoever i can and
actually forward with life and that's
scary and i have no idea what will
happen but i'm going to do it that is
kind of where she's been building she's
been consistently kind of going on that
track and so the idea reconnecting with
these people which was kind of American
for her and really in the firm to choice
but then throughout the last season it
was this sort of fear and we were just
kind of living broken down I you know
the terminus people so that trust was
like I'll iterated and then it's like
going into you know the idea of going
into what happened to Bob and it was
just constant like what happened to the
church like it was just the constant
breaking down and then she started to
see people like Glen start to get broken
down and how his psyche started to shift
and stuff like that an idea that we
could actually get to the point where
things could get like we actually all
turn into where she's been was very
scary for her it's interesting because
it just shows the importance of this of
this group of people because there's
always this sort of sine wave of sanity
where it's like oh Gabriel's not doing
so great it's not just losing it Rick's
I'm not sure I gave a show is good
Carol's good she just tried to murder a
kid you know like so
you guys come and meet each other right
to valley balance I'd be like Michelle
was a very she was a very calm presence
throughout and all right sort of
resigned at the end of like here we
go oh yeah he does this crazy thing from
like that the moment of actually you
know say not gonna neutralize Rick which
to me was like was really like
disturbing moment to play online oh dang
I got a hunch I'm for it yeah you know
you know strangely you don't get a good
time we good right yeah but it was such
a weird moment to have to do but it was
it was like that freaking a part of
thing I think differently from you and
I'm going to do something different what
you do did get me oh yeah I won't allow
the best freak yeah she came for real
hurry up Grandage jumped on me up today
did they say come and just come I hope
that's good acting what are you talking
about I thought I'd really locked him up
but now at the end of it when we
actually you know picking up that sort
again that was when you realize okay i
have got to balances out because there's
no way i can put my weapon up there and
walk away from my power when people
other people pick it up and use it for
bad trust myself to use it for good so
that's interesting so what was even so
much like a battle weapon is like a
protection from other people I've ever
been yeah well it is a protective force
if I'm using a trip but if someone to
mother dude porch dick picks it up well
he's not gonna be picking anything up at
this point excuse prey on top of this I
you